Please tell me what inspired you to write this book.
Well, I always loved math in school.
And when I graduated with a degree in mathematics,...
...I noticed how many people were so shocked and stunned...
...that I had gone into math.
They said, "But you're an actress."
"Why are you studying math?"
"You know, math is for nerds."
I was so horrified.
And I noticed so many women especially saying, "Oh, I can't do math."
"I was never good at math."
And I wanted to show them...
...that you don't have to be a certain kind of person to love math...
...and to do well at math.
So, I wanted to help girls embrace the idea of being smart.
And embrace the idea that they could be smart with math.
And they could be fabulous and popular and anything else they wanna be.
They can be anybody they want,...
...and studying math and being smart makes it better.